janina ich bin tatsächlich gerade eben
wieder gekommen von einem interview mit
witali klitschko dem bürgermeister und
alle reden über den angeblichen abzug
hier aus kiew und dass die russischen
truppen doch schon so gut wie weg sein
und jetzt der große frieden kommt ich
übertreibe wie du hörst aber vitali
klitschko der kam gerade von der front
oder sagte da wird weiterhin heftig
gekämpft in bravery zum beispiel ein
vorort von kiew und er sagt er glaubt
der russischen armee gar nichts denn sie
wurden hier nur belogen 1 1994 als man
die atomwaffen abgegeben hat gegen eine
sicherheitsgarantie die da nichts wert
war und dann der krieg der nicht kommen
sollte und jetzt diese ankündigung dass
man angeblich einen teilabzug mache
viele menschen in der ukraine
eingeschlossen viele politiker glauben
dass das ganze ein taktischer rückzug
ist weil man hier nicht weitergekommen
ist in der hauptstadt um sich jetzt zu
rekrutieren im dombach den bombast ganz
zu erobern und da es erneut zu versuchen
richtung kirche zu kommen
und du hast uns heute auch eine these
mitgebracht paul die dich ja sehr bewegt
so ist es nicht ich glaube nach all dem
was wir in diesen tagen erlebt haben in
diesen wochen erlebt haben in diesen
jahren erlebt haben was deutsche
politiker im umgang mit russland im
umgang mit wladimir putin im umgang mit
dem kreml angeht brauchen wir dringend
einen untersuchungsausschuss nach dem
krieg und zwar muss untersucht werden
welche motive wirklich dahinter steckten
was frank walter steinmeier der
kanzleramtsminister außenminister und
jetzige bundespräsident dort mit
wladimir putin und la france besprochen
hat wie eng der bund war was mit gerhard
schröder passiert ist aber auch was
angela merkel wirklich angetrieben hat
so lange so deutlich hinter wladimir
putin zu stehen ich bin dafür dass
aktuelle und ehemalige politiker in
diesem zusammenhang durchleuchtet werden
sollten denn wir brauchen in deutschland
eine neue aufklärung eine aufklärung
über das was wir lange zeit in richtung
russland getan haben nur so können wir
überhaupt wieder vertrauen
zurückgewinnen auch in der international
ein schaf wenn man sich in diesen tagen
mit amerikanern austauscht auch mit
briten die fragen immer nur was war da
los bei euren politikern loos jan
die frage die ich mir gerade stelle kann
man denn nicht auch sagen dass so
absprachen unter der hand auch ein
beitrag zur demokratie sein können
das kann natürlich einen beitrag zur
demokratie sein aber ich finde den
vorschlag den paul gemacht hat
mindestens diskussionswürdig wenn ich
sogar auch am ende einen den man ins
parlament tragen muss um genau darüber
auch zu sprechen ich befürchte
allerdings auch lieber paul dass die
meisten politiker oder wenn es um diese
untersuchungsausschuss geht die meisten
parteien er damit verdeckten karten
spielen werden bis auf fdp und grüne die
zuletzt eine doch deutliche distanz zum
kreml hatten sind eigentlich alle
anderen parteien im bundestag vertreten
sind ja in irgendeiner art und weise
dann mit dem kreml verbandelt will ich
nicht sagen aber pflegten doch mehr oder
weniger starke beziehungen in den kreml
also angefangen natürlich von der
linkspartei über die spd über die union
bis hin zur afg von daher glaube ich
dass dieser ausschuss wichtig wäre der
erkenntnisgewinn am ende wahrscheinlich
nicht so großes einfach weil es zu viele
interessen gibt zuviel organisierten
widerstand also unser image ist da
teilweise dadurch nicht gut ich war vor
zehn tagen noch in amerika und ich hatte
einen ober fahrer ein ukrainischer sagte
ja vom germany und so ja er war sehr
nett zu russland viel zu nett also dass
das registrieren die auch das kann
sinnvoll sein rückwärts etwas zu
untersuchen ich glaube vorwärts jetzt
die sanktionen noch zu verschärfen
ist noch wichtig wenn sie gehen herr
maschmeyer beim verschärfen ich würde so
weit gehen dass wir kein russisches gas
und öl
neben aus russland wir sind ja dann
nicht sofort dass wir hier eine eiszeit
haben und nichts mehr geht wir können
aus norwegen aus großbritannien aus usa
öl und gas bekommen wahrscheinlich wird
es teurer wir können noch mehr erdwärme
machen wir können auch die
atomkraftwerke die wenigen die wir noch
haben noch ein bisschen länger laufen
lassen und vielleicht sogar noch ein
bisschen länger kohle wir kriegen
atomstrom aus nachbarländern frankreich
schaltet nichts ab die bauern sogar drei
neue atomkraftwerke
wir sollten das probieren erst wenn der
druck so hochkommt und vielleicht das
geld wenn die berechnungen stimmen für
die kriegsmaschine da ist dann ist
vielleicht noch er ist möglich dass die
schreckliche krieg diese sauerei von
krieg aufhört rosi
untersuchungsausschuss was hältst du von
teese theorie oder herr martenstein
beide wie es ihrer meinung nach aus ich
bin eine grundsätzlich muss die
priorität eins muss es sein diesen krieg
zu beenden ich mich jeden tag wo das
länger geht ist damit das elend
monumental zeichen mit ich hab dich
einfach nicht irgendwie ohne das zu
wissen ich habe anfang des jahres ein
leitartikel geschrieben wird das motto
ist eigentlich friedliche koexistenz und
jetzt plötzlich auf zwei jahren corona
landen wir in diesem fürchterlichen
krieg denn im ersten unsichtbar und
feind jetzt ernsthaft das muss man
stoppen ich würde aber ortung von
solchen
untersuchungskommissionen das wird dann
auch für politische schaukämpfe für
abrechnungen benutzt das sind und die
gerichtshöfe der moral jeder der einmal
putin die hand geschüttelt hat wird dann
je nach politischer ausrichtung da
angeprangert das kann auch ein paar auch
noch unangenehm die reine die
journalisten wahrscheinlich wollen also
1000 sagt das könnte auch unangenehm
werden für einige könnte auch unangenehm
werden für einige journalisten wenn man
noch alte titel und alte leitartikel
rauskommt und jeder sehen und ich bin
auch noch gegen diese
inquisitorischen
verfahren und ich meine deutschland
hatte eine geschichte von 800 jahren
beziehungen mit russland ich meine das
ist ja nicht einfach war sie jetzt aus
dem jetzigen zustand danach zu
beurteilen und man muss den leuten bei
der rechtsstaat muss geld wenn einer ein
gesetz verlängert weil etwas eingestellt
sollte gesagt hat dann muss man ihn
jetzt vor gericht wehren wenn einmal
daran gedacht trotzdem das muss ich dann
schon mal sagen wir reden hier über den
größten kriegsverbrecher im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert und es gab
in diesem bundestag viele viele
politiker die mit herrn putin so
umgegangen sind als wäre das die
ihk in paris und ich glaube dass es da
schon extreme unterschiede gibt und es
deswegen auch das recht ist auch der
bundesbürger zu wissen wer hat
eigentlich wie mit diesem
kriegsverbrecher gekungelt wer hat
eigentlich wie die lsk oder ist
zumindest drauf reingefallen und hat man
doch mal
schön dann also dass er einen
kriegsverbrecher dieser dimension werden
würde war vor einigen jahren nicht
abzusehen auch beste russland kenner
haben sich ja überrascht gezeigt darüber
dass putin tatsächlich da einmarschiert
ist also ich bin kein russland könnte
ich lese das was sie schreiben und
offensichtlich also man kann von den
menschen nicht verlangen dass sie
hellseher sind würde ich da sagen
ich wünsche mir sehr dass wir also
deutschland mehr für die ukraine tun
denn klar der krieg soll ende möglichst
bald aber ich wünsche mir nicht dass er
damit endet dass putin seine ziele
erreicht nämlich die ukraine zu einer
art kolonie zu machen und irgend eine
marionette an die spitze zu setzen zu
einem weißrussland nur einem total
kaputten und zerbombten und weißrussland
aus dem dann alle menschen geflohen sind
ja das sollte nicht passieren weil das
eine riesige ermutigung wäre weltweit
für leute für diktatoren die appetit auf
einander hat china hunger auf teure ja
also das sollte nicht passieren und
deswegen und da sind wir wieder bei der
geheimen seite der politik ich hätte
überhaupt nichts dagegen wenn wir die
ukraine mit mit waffen unterstützen und
zwar in größerem umfang als das bisher
bekannt ist denn ich gestehe ich hoffe
dass die ukraine diesen konflikt gewinnt
das ist bei kleinen schlusswort denn wir
sind am ende der sendung angekommen ich
bedanke mich sehr bei meinen gästen und
natürlich auch bei paul ronzheimer der
uns live unsere ukraine zugeschaltet war
und jetzt schönen abend noch ein bis
morgen 20 15